jeff van gundy on the call for espn abc
and uh what was your reaction when you
heard that charles said if the blazers
win last night they'll sweep the lakers
well interestingly i had said just the
opposite the day before
on a show i said that i thought
that the lakers had a better opportunity
of sweeping
the blazers than the blazers had of
winning the series
and last night
you know portland shot under 40 percent
from the floor
and they still won and so
um i got to give them a lot of credit i
think they were hardened
you know you know because they had to
win so many games
and just like milwaukee you know at the
end of one
uh the lakers were down double-digit and
so they were
playing from behind the whole night yeah
and they've been doing that every single
game in the bubble
if i didn't watch the game last night
how would you sum up why
the lakers lost
awful shooting you know five for 32 from
three
terrible from the free throw line lebron
and anthony davis were
a combined 16 for 24 and then lebron and
anthony davis who have to absolutely
carry them offensively
uh davis was eight for 24. lebron was
nine for 20. so
you know it was a substandard night
offensively all the way around
they didn't turn it over they played
really hard they
were up on the backboard but
their offensive skill is very limited
james and davis have to be great
yeah i think anthony davis night in a
night out though coach has got to be the
best player on the floor
and these are the first real important
games of his career
and i don't know if you ease into the
playoffs it felt like he lets
the action sometimes come to him he
needs to be more aggressive
and i don't know how lebron can
facilitate that
you know can you change somebody's
personality because it might just be
anthony davis's personality
well i don't think you ever change
somebody's personality but you can
help them to reach whatever maximum
level of intensity
they can you know la all year has been
dynamic in transition
and davis got a couple in transition
last night
but they've struggled in half court
they're they just don't have a lot of
weapons
when you think about it who else is
going to be able to create a shot
other than james or davis
um without rondo avery bradley i think
they miss his defense and off the ball
cutting
and movement i'm interested to see
do they put in somebody like waiters
to try to have another guy who can go
off the dribble
he only played a minute last night so
i'm just interested their starting unit
it just doesn't they didn't play well
and they haven't played well
offensively in the half court talking to
jeff van gundy espn abc
analyst he'll be on the call on thursday
oklahoma city and the rockets and then
it'll be the lakers and blazers
if i'm portland what do i want the
lakers
what am i forcing or trying to get the
lakers to do
well i think what you want to do is
make sure you do a better job of keeping
anthony davis off the line
and then i would double him on every low
post or mid
post catch and make that ball go to the
other lakers
and see if they have enough offense on
the weak side
and i think if the lakers are
able to get through this series i have
no doubts
that they're going to every team that
plays them is going to try to test
the lakers to see if they have enough
offense uh
in the half court and
if you don't give the lakers transition
if you're terry studs right we turned
the ball over
16 times and that led to some breakouts
but if we can just keep them in the half
court make them shoot it up over the top
they won't shoot five for 32 from three
but do they have enough shooting
and then portland i didn't know i
thought they might be on fumes
you know that adrenaline and you've
coached against teams with teams that
they just
seem to be relying on something
internally and portland still has that
last night and i also thought
the big men uh proved to be a pretty big
difference for that team
when i didn't think whiteside you know
who doesn't play that much but then
they relied on him last night you just
got a nice team contribution
and that's a team that's a better
all-around overall top to bottom team
than the lakers are
well i thought the you know winning the
play-in game on the first night
um gave them that extra day off
so that they had two days off in between
games
uh to plan and to recharge
and the thing i think uh terry starts
his team
you know none of those guys had a big
night last night none of them
no one shot well they won shooting under
40 percent but they got to the free
throw line
and uh like you said they got some
timely contributions white side
uh nurkish shouldn't have a particularly
big night but i thought
you know he did some good things uh
lillard's bomb
obviously was an incredible shot but
they can if i'm terry stotts i'm saying
we can play a lot better
and we're going to need to play better
because certainly the lakers aren't
going to shoot like that
i just thought they were more ready and
when you know doug collins used to
always say
the nba is not a fourth quarter league
it's a first quarter league
and the team that's ready can play with
a cushion
uh the entire night and that's exactly
what happened
you know for portland uh they were up
double digits at the end of one
and that cushion allowed them to play
free and with great confidence
barkley at one point last night
halftime i think rockets and the thunder
said that
james harden is i think the most
unstoppable one-on-one player
that he's ever seen what do you make of
that
well i think certainly in this era
with these rules the spacing is so much
greater now
the rules are tilted entirely to
the offensive player um his skill level
in this era of nba basketball
uh of one on one uh
and the team he's on and how they
structured their team
gives him maximum room he's unguardable
and so if
if you are unguardable um
to me oklahoma city is going to look
back
in that first game with regret that
they allowed him other than schroeder
they didn't really play him with great
discipline they fouled him
on jump shots i
i just think that houston when you look
at hardin
and all that he is required to do for
that team
he and doncic i don't think any two guys
and maybe james two maybe those three
they have such a burden to create every
good shot that you're going to get
offensively
to have the stamina to do that it
requires true true greatness and i agree
with
charles that you know harden has done it
for a long period of time in houston
and he's done it exceptionally well yeah
i i mean he's a powerful guy he gets you
on his hip
he can he can shoot the three uh he's
got great feet he can get to the hoop
there
but i always go back to the most
unstoppable player of all time is kareem
because nobody ever stopped that sky
hook now granted he couldn't create his
own shot unless
you know magic threw it in there but i
always go
kareem would be the one guy
that that shot was never stopped
well that stuff and then you know wilt
in a different time
you know er era of basketball
you know i i don't know why wilt's
numbers
get overlooked the discrepancy between
when he won a fourth title
and next best right was like it was
always like
these staggering differences and you
know
like i don't know why maybe because the
the lane was different
and you know we don't have as much video
but
it's jeff i brought this up about babe
ruth why is it we celebrate
babe ruth in what he did and we don't
have any video of that
but we look at him as the greatest
player of all time
wilt is babe ruth you know obviously
without the titles but the stats
he dwarfs everybody and we don't we
don't recognize those i agree
well and also you know what's funny
about that like
without the titles he won two titles
like we talk about it like this guy
didn't win
he did he just didn't win as much as
russell
right and russell played with you know
in this incredible time and
you think about the stats that will put
up and those guys put up
there were only eight teams they were
playing the eight
the seven other best centers in the
world
all the time they didn't get to pick on
center number
28 and 29 like in today's nba
like like what will did like and like
you said about kareem too like
kareem like because it looks so easy
people don't real the amount of physical
contact
that was allowed on perimeter players
post players and still today
post players but there's just not that
many of them but the amount of contact
and how different the rules
were the rules back then were all tilted
for the defense
you know there wasn't freedom but
movement there wasn't
there was hand checking there was body
blows there was no flagrant fouls
i mean it's like to score in that era
the way kareem did and so effortlessly
um you're right the sky hook is
absolutely the most indefensible shot
that i've ever seen in the nba well and
you go back to the mavericks and the
clippers
you know when you had porzingis getting
involved with morris 20 years ago
they wouldn't have stopped playing like
you would have just said play on like
there
there that would have been nothing but
you know that
is a prime example of you know the way
the nba
is now and uh you know what they're
trying to protect or enforce
but you know when you were coaching you
probably had a few of those dust up
every single night nobody's getting teed
up yeah
i i i think common sense
has to prevail you know the porzingis
ejection
i had as much problem with the first
technical as i did with the second
and to me
both things were not overtly
disrespectful that it could lead you to
an ejection now i'm not saying that
officials were wrong dan
but the policies are wrong i've read so
many times that
we're trying to take the decision making
out of officiating
that's nonsense officiating
is about being able to make decisions
advantage disadvantage
um it's the same with players the
difference with players who can make
better decisions
it's not just who has better skills it's
how to use a skill when to use a skill
so
i think sometimes we take perverse
pleasure in the mba
in being tough on crime in like we're
gonna show them
you know there's no air punches does
anybody even hear
like truly is there's a difference
between
an air punch directed at somebody you're
walking to some
official versus a natural reaction and i
just
feel like you know long ago i think it
was bill
uh bill simmons who first said it but
maybe i'm wrong that every organization
needs a vice president of common sense
and i think when we're talking about mba
officiating common sense is so important
um decision making is so important
policies that try to keep our best
players on the floor versus figure out
ways to get them off the floor
um i just think make for a better game
if i had you and your brother have a
free throw shooting contest where you
shot 25
each who would win
well he's a better shooter but i think
his conditioning would um
his lack of conditioning he may really
fatigue after
15 straight free throws and if it's
outside in the heat
i've got it he would absolutely wilt
yes uh and i'll leave you with this i
was watching
the clippers play against the mavs and
kawhi leonard
struck me as if i was going to attach a
soundtrack to players
his would be like miles davis there's a
there's a
a jazz feel to kawhi leonard
and i don't know why i thought that but
it just felt like
he moves at a different speed and a
different
grace about him i don't know but i'm
curious if we
started attaching soundtracks to certain
players by the way they played
that might be interesting i don't know
you know that's actually good i don't
know too much about music
but he does play at his own pace and
rhythm
he's he's not easy to speed up because
of his strength and his size so you know
you were talking earlier about somebody
getting somebody on their hip like
harden
and then you can go at your own pace i
feel doncic is the same
way he looks like a middle linebacker
like
at the point guard position and he's not
fleet of foot but
when he gets a a half a step on you it's
hard to recover and get back in front
and these guys with this skill at their
size
and their strength and the vision they
have
it's really hard to guard now you know
you combine everything rules
spacing amount of shooting around it's
like
video game type numbers these guys are
putting up in
and leonard can seemingly get a good
shot anytime he wants to
and i did bring this up the other day so
full disclosure where i said you know
luca is better than larry bird
right now at the same age because larry
was still in college
and doncic has been playing against
grown men since he was
15. and his the way he plays
what was larry when he got into the
league 23 maybe
24 because he sat out a year uh when he
quit
indiana like luca where he is now it's
not unheard of to say he's going to be a
better basketball player
than larry bird yeah
i think like for me comparison is the
thief of joy
because someone feels diminished i know
when
when you start saying things and i think
sometimes we jump ahead of ourselves
when we say a young player is like an
all-time great because
the true um measuring stick of the
all-time greats
is the consistency right so bird had
this everyday consistency
over a long period of time you know why
is jabar one of the
you know you know could be the greatest
or jordan right they did it for
for a long period of time why is lebron
james considered one of the greatest if
not the greatest
it's the consistency over time and
really
i don't see anything being able to get
in lucas way
to achieving that type of status
if his health holds up because the guy
has skill
he has passion uh he has vision
like if you have all of that that's what
larry bird that's
that's what he had and that's what
doncic has and i
you know whether he's going to have the
same
team success that bird had remains to be
seen and it's so dependent on who they
can surround him with
but certainly dodger just heading to be
an all-time great
if his health and that's why i you know
zion makes me
nervous you know he he's must see tv and
he's
explosive but you know when you're in a
race with your body
you know to stay in shape and be able to
perform like that
luca is going to be able to play the
same way he's playing now
probably in 10 years from now because
it's not predicated on
hey he's so explosive or he's so quick
or whatever
it just feels like he plays like an old
guy does when you you go to a playground
and some guy who's 50
who played you know in the ivy league
and you're going well that guy's
unstoppable
he just he knows how to play the game
and i think that
what you see now is probably what we'll
see in 10 years from now and i can't
make that same claim with zion
hey dan there's no one that played like
uh doncic
at harvard yale okay
no but you're right as far as you know
he's not relying
on straight and true athleticism
and he has
two areas he can improve on like
which will make him again unguardable in
today's game
he's he's a below average three-point
shooter and he's a sub
80 percent free throw shooter for a guy
who lives at the line
you just have you know slow incremental
progress in both of those areas over the
next five years
i mean now you're dealing with let's
just say he gets to be an
average or slightly above average
three-point shooter
and there's no reason he shouldn't be an
80-plus free-throw shooter
you know and maybe he reduces his
turnovers you know
by you know maybe half or one a game
those things at the margins make him
significantly better i mean
i think he has still potential to grow i
think he's going to be a multiple time
mvp award winner because
of the opportunity he has in dallas um
and his greatness great to talk to you
jeff as always thanks we appreciate your
time
all right take care that's jeff van
gundy he'll be on the call
on thursday at 3 30 eastern oklahoma
city taking on the rockets and then at
nine
blazers lakers